i got to play this for you canada's
official indigenous health expert
and that's a position that exists in
canada apparently her name is carrie
barosa and she has always been
very open about her native american
ancestry
she wears you know native american garb
and and when she goes on she gives talks
she she identifies by the name chief
running bear or something like that
and she talks a lot about the racism
that she's experienced so she's very
open about it in fact here are some
clips of her on
a couple clips here she's on some news
programs and then she also did a ted
talk
where she's talking about indigenous
issues let's watch that
unfortunately
many people that access healthcare feel
stigmatized they
will might experience racism or
prejudice and whether it's perceived or
it's real when you're experiencing it
it's very real have you experienced it i
have i have experienced it my
great-grandmother was clinkid she
married an immigrant
they moved from
the far northern bc
into saskatchewan and they had a family
greetings
my name is morning star bear
i'm just going to say i'm emotional so
[Applause]
i'm bear clan i'm an anishinabe metis
from treaty for territory and i want to
acknowledge the territory that i'm in 36
territory
home to the kree peoples and uh
homeland of the metis nation
i also want to acknowledge my ancestors
who are clearly here with me
that's uh
that's tough you know that she
wow
now she's just getting real really
emotional about her native american
ancestry uh uh morning sorry not chief
running bear she's a uh more what was it
morning star
morning star bear it's not funny i mean
that's that's her that's her ancestral
name who am i to make fun of not making
fun of it um
but now let's let's get an update on
this story this is from the new york
post it says a canadian medical
researcher who rose to become the
nation's top voice on indigenous
healthcare has been ousted from her
government job and her university
professorship after suspicious
colleagues investigated her increasingly
fanciful claims of native american
heritage and learned she was a fraud
so it turns out they did a they they
looked into this and they did a lot of
research about it
and uh it turns out that she does not
she's not a native american so she
pulled an elizabeth warren but unlike
elizabeth warren elizabeth warren got
the exception and uh and she got to get
out of jail free car she got out she got
the get out of jail
free card for her appropriation and
there's only one of them and she got it
so carrie barossa morningstar bear is
not going to get it it turns out they
did they traced her family tree
i don't know how exactly they did this i
don't know if they obtained a dna sample
against her will or something
they took from a you know a drinking
glass that she was drinking and took the
dna sample i don't know what they did
but they traced her her family heritage
and they discovered that she is really
uh descended from immigrant farmers from
russia and poland in czechoslovakia well
we are doing christmas at our house this
year which is which is how i like we
don't have to travel and everything but
um you know when you have guests over
for for the holiday season you always
will make sure you you're impressing
them with all of your fancy belongings
and this is how i'll be pronounced
impressing my
christmas uh uh guests this is the
kamikoto knives uh that i've just
received and um you know we actually
just needed hold on can i pull these out
the other thing with these knives is
they're very very sharp so i probably
shouldn't be doing this at all chemical
makes great japanese steel kitchen
knives using traditional techniques from
japan kamigodo taps into more than 800
years of traditional techniques from
honshu japan kamikoto also only uses
steel source from mills in japan and
each blade is crafted using techniques
that have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths and again
they're very very sharp so you don't
want to be doing exactly what i'm doing
right here knives are not toys i tell my
kids all the time unless i'm playing
with them each knife comes in a
beautiful heavy duty ash wood box and
make sure that the the gif the knife is
stored safely it also makes kamikoto a
great gift
each chemical knife goes through a
rigorous 19-step process that takes
several years from start to finish to
complete and you can tell just when you
hold them in your hand uh how well-made
these these knives are our expert blade
smiths forge and shape raw steel into
hardy blades polishing and sharpening
them to an excruciatingly fine edge each
knife is individually inspected chemical
is so confident about their knives that
each knife comes with a lifetime
guarantee these things are so so fine
and sharp you could cut your finger off
and you wouldn't even notice until the
fingers laying on the floor
because of their single bevel edge
kamikoto knives can achieve an
unbelievably sharp edge you just can't
get with other knives they can cut
through your rib eye like butter they
can cut through you know your body parts
everything chemical knives are used by
several chefs working at michelin star
restaurants so click the link below or
go to
kamikoto.com walsh and use promo code
matt walsh to save an extra
50
today so
two things about this
one is again we have more proof
that the mainstream narrative of
systemic oppression
is false
the
the version of systemic oppression the
the narrative of systemic oppression
that we get from the reality curators is
completely false because if made of if
indigenous people
were persecuted if they were repressed
then and you were not in the oppressed
group
you in fact were in the you were in the
dominant group allegedly you would not
pretend to be in the oppressed group
because it would not benefit you
these people
do this because they know it will
benefit them and it does
until until the ruse is discovered
but also
you would think if you're trying to
score points off of the suffering of
your ancestors
which you shouldn't be able to do
okay in a in a in a normal and a sane
society you wouldn't be able to do that
the fact that your ancestors suffered
should that shouldn't do anything for
you because it's not your suffering
but if you were if that's what this was
about
then you would think that your ancestors
being polish farmers
you wouldn't why not just go with that
why not go with the truth
polish farmers i mean these were
probably people who lived pretty
difficult lives
i don't know about you i wouldn't i
wouldn't want to trace i wouldn't want
to trade places with a polish farmer
from the 19th century
but they don't count that's why because
their suffering doesn't count because
they were basically white and so that's
why that doesn't count
and then but the second thing we can
take from this or the question we can
ask i guess is um
really more of a rhetorical question
because i know the answer but
uh of course why why can't she identify
as a native american
why is this not a valid thing
she feels connected with native american
culture
she identifies with it
this is her truth
um she has transitioned
okay she's she's living that truth
doesn't harm anybody else
this is what we're always told about
trans people right that's what we're all
we're always well if somebody wants to
live that way doesn't harm you what
difference does it make
if this is what they want to identify
what does it matter
same thing should apply here
only as i always say even more so
you know the person claiming to be trans
racial or trans ethnic
their
their claim is more credible
is more defensible it's still not
credible and not defensible but it's
more credible and more defensible
than the transgender claim
because we know that races and
ethnicities are in fact fluid
okay they they combine culture is also
very fluid
it changes over time it has different
influences and so on
you can actually be a mix of different
races and different ethnicities i mean
almost everybody is
whereas with sex that's not the case
you're either male or female
so you would think
that this would be a perfectly valid
thing that a person could do
but but they can't because it doesn't
fit with the narrative and i know that
you know another thing you hear from the
right a lot is that this is part of the
slippery slope and so uh right now we've
got the transgender thing and eventually
we'll be in a spot where uh we're
expected to accept trans-racial also
but no because this is not this is not a
slippery slope situation
on the slippery slope the idea is that
the next thing is always more outrageous
and more absurd and more grotesque right
but transracial is actually farther up
on on the slope
because it's more again more defensible
and more credible
we've we we have leapfrogged over
transracial we're not doing that
you know what the only problem with the
slippery slope idea
um
is that
there's
it doesn't always follow a logical
progression
because it's not like we're sliding down
this slope
by happenstance
we are being steered down by cultural
forces
and so there are certain things that you
would think would be part of the logical
progression that they kind of steer
around because they don't want to do
that one the transracial thing we're not
doing
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated